Major breaking news as the Democratic
Party in the state of Virginia is in big
time trouble when it comes to their
effort to essentially switch out five
Republican seats in the United States
House of Representatives to become
Democratic House seats. Things are not
going as planned. And guess what? A
reason for this is because of their
effort to push through gun control.
You're not going to want to miss this
detailed breakdown and some critical
facts and data that I think will make
you ultimately happy. Let's break it
down when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four boxes diner, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and proud to say the top voice the
second amendment in America backtoback
years 2025 2026 thanks to Gundy's
awards. All right, folks. For those of
you who may be out in Arizona later this
week, I will be giving the keynote
address on Friday night at the Gun
Owners of America annual uh activist
dinner. So, uh if you happen to be out
there in Arizona going to one of the Gun
Owners of America events, stop on by and
say hello. I appreciate talking with
you. All right, folks. So, this is
exciting news. Now, you know, I don't
like any of the gun control law that's
occurring in Virginia. hasn't happened
yet, but it seems to be on the verge of
becoming law in that state as the House
and the Senate in Virginia have enacted
about nine different gun control laws.
And they've sent it to Abigail
Spanberger, the governor, former CIA
agent or employee at least, uh sent it
to her desk for signing. As you
remember, under Virginia law, uh
Governor Spanberger can sign these gun
control laws or she can simply not sign
them and they go into effect or at least
be they're deemed passed on April 13,
2026. Now, here's the big deal, folks.
This is why you tune into the Four Boxes
Diner channel to hear things you won't
hear anywhere else. The Democrats are in
big trouble and about to pay a national
price potentially, a national price
potentially for their game games when it
comes to the right to bear arms in
Virginia. What do I mean by this?
Remember that Virginia is one of the
states that is trying to take as many
House seats from the United States
Congress from Republicans and give it to
Democrats through the process of
gerrymandering. Mid decade
gerrymandering, meaning between the 2020
and the 2030 census. Now, here's the
key. It turns out, according to all
reporting and all data, that the
Republicans in the red areas are turning
out dramatically in favor, it appears,
of shutting down and stopping this
attempt to take five Republican House
seats and give it to the Democrats.
Overwhelmingly, the Republicans seem to
be turning out the votes much better
than the Democrats, which means that the
Democrats may fail to capture these five
House seats they've been counting on in
Virginia that if they capture will
dramatically increase the chances of
them taking over the United States House
of Representatives after the midterm
election this coming November. And one
of the big motivators here in Virginia
is their big push, maybe the Democrat's
big push for gun control. Now, here's
the key facts in terms of the dates. The
decision as to whether or not Governor
Spanberger will sign the gun control
bills and or allow them to take effect
simply by doing nothing. That key date
is April 13th. April 13, 2026.
What is the date of the election and the
voting for the so-called redistricting
constitutional amendment to change the
Virginia constitution
to basically allow them to engage in
this mid decade gerrymandering to take
away five Republican seats and give it
to the Democrats making it go from six
Democratic houses house members to five
Republican House members to make it go
from six to five in favor of the
Democrats to 10 to one to 10 to one. 10
Democrats for one Republican House seat
after these redistricting if this
redistricting effort it actually
succeeds. If this amendment passes come
April, but the dilemma that the
Democrats now face and they did it to
themselves. Remember I teach you it's
very important to look down the
chessboard. Maybe the Democrats didn't
do a very good job because by rushing
through the gun control bills that will
basically be decided upon fully on April
13th, that is over a week before the big
vote on the redistricting effort. And if
there are people in Virginia that want
to punish the Democrats for their games
and pushing through all this gun
control, the best way to do it will be
to shut down this attempt to redraw the
congressional lines to give the
Democrats five additional House seats in
the US Representatives. In the US House
of Representatives. That's right. Now,
we let me tell you where things are in
Virginia now based on all the best
reporting so far. And then we're going
to show that there is indeed many
historical precedents both at the
federal level and in Virginia itself
showing that when they play games with
the right to bear arms, the Democrats
pay a serious serious political penalty.
But let's start with where the early
turnout is in terms of who is voting for
or against this redistricting mid decade
redistricting effort by the Democrats in
Virginia. Let's check out what NBC NBC
News has to say about this very topic
right now. Not a done deal. Democrats
start to sweat over Virginia's
redistricting referendum. The unique
nature of the April special election and
the state's recent redistricting history
have presented challenges for the
Democrats, even as they hold a financial
edge in the race. NBC News goes on to
say, "After putting an aggressive redraw
of the state's congressional map before
voters, some Virginia Democrats are
growing uneasy about his prospects for
passage one month out from the special
election. Some supporters of the
Virginia referendum acknowledged the
challenge of convincing voters to back a
gerrymandered map when Democrats who
several years ago backed the formation
back the formation of the state's
bipartisan redistricting commission have
criticized Republicans for similar
moves. That's right. And guess what
Larry Sabatol, the head of the
University of Virginia Center for
Politics is specifically said? There's
real issues here. It's not a done deal.
Here's what he has to say about where we
stand with this redistricting effort and
the Democrats attempt to basically take
over five House seats for themselves
away from the Republican party. Here's
what he has to say. Check it out. It is
reported that quote, "Tens of millions
of dollars in early votes are flowing
into Virginia's statewide redistricting
memorandum that if passed would allow
Democrats to redraw congressional lines
and pick up four additional seats in
Congress ahead of the midterm
elections." While most of that money has
gone to one side of the issue,
preliminary early voting turnout data
has followed a different trend. Larry
Sabatode, the director of the University
of Virginia Center for Politics, says
the following. They want to overcome the
five seats that Texas Republicans took.
He goes on to say, though, that a
victory is not assured at all. This is
very exciting news, folks, because
according to the early polling,
according to some of the the early
polling that's been done here, for
example, the Rono College poll
specifically found that 62% like the way
the congressional maps are drawn right
here and right now. And that's very
favorable because if the status quo is
continued, then that means those five
Republican seats, those four or five
Republican seats will not disappear. And
that will help dramatically the
opportunity or the chances of Donald
Trump and the Republican party
maintaining control of the House of
Representatives this fall which we
really need for a whole bunch of reasons
including to continue to push that most
important issue which is even which is
the most important issue when it comes
to our second amendment right to keeps
and that is the immigration issue
kicking out the people shouldn't be
here. kicking out the people that may be
illegally voting, kicking out the people
that have no interest in the right to
keep and bear arms. Because keep in mind
in Virginia, the Bangladeshyborn senator
from Virginia is specifically the one
that was pushing through this gun
control law. As to why someone who was
born outside of the United States in
some third real crappy country gets to
come to the United States and take away
our fundamental rights given to us by
our founding fathers is simply absurd.
Which goes back to my view that both
illegal immigration and legal
immigration need to be shut down and
stopped by and large entirely. as far as
I'm concerned. And those of you disagree
with me, well, I'm simply right because
the record shows that we have massive
influxes of immigration, for example, in
places like Virginia where you have like
1.2 million last I checked, 1.2 million
people that have been born outside the
United States who currently live in
Virginia. Don't tell me that that is not
influencing American politics in
Virginia. And don't tell me those are
Republican voters because we know
they're simply not. Okay, but let's
carry on. The Washington Post has
already been reporting that there is a
very good chance of backlash because
there's a much stronger engagement in
the areas where the five Republican
congressmen or Congress people are
currently serving. And the rural red
areas are outperforming the blue urban
centers. And this is according to the
Washington Post. And by the way, there
is historical evidence in Virginia of
when you do crazy stuff against guns,
there is a backlash. Let's just step
back to the year of our lord 2020. In
2020, the Democrats took over, I think,
the House of Delegates and they had
control of all sorts of other things.
There was this big push and they enacted
a bunch of gun control laws back in
2020. And guess what happened in 2021?
Governor Glenn Yncan was elected. So
that was in part a backlash to the gun
issue. And by the way, there's
historical precedent for this because
how many of you remember that in the
year of our Lord? 1994,
1994. In September, what did President
Bill Clinton do and his buddy buddies in
the Democratic Party? In September of
1994,
they enacted the so-called assault
weapon ban. And in November 1994, they
got spanked span spanked by N. Gingrich
of the Republican party. That N.
Gingrich of the Republican party took
over the House of Representatives for
the first time since like the 1950s,
just a couple months after Bill Clinton
signed the so-called assault weapon ban.
And the Republicans also turned over
that November 20ou that November of
1994, the US Senate, another example of
the backlash that comes around with
playing games of gun control law. And I
also want to remind you in 1993, a year
before uh the new Gingrich take over the
House and the Senate take over by the
Republicans in November 1994, a year
earlier in 1993, you had that terrible
Waco uh debacle uh down there in Waco,
Texas, which you don't need to, you
know, blavorver the point there, but
again, it's further proof that you can
have a backlash on other issues in a
huge way if you start messing with the
gun issues. So, right here, right now,
we know that there's nine different gun
control bills in various formats that
are going to that have been sent to
Abigail Spamberger's desk at the
governor's mansion. She has to make a
decision, yay or nay, by April 13th. But
8 days later, Virginia are going to turn
to the polls. And the question is, will
there be backlash that slaps the
Democrats down and says, "No, you cannot
take those four or five House seats and
give them to the Democrats. You don't
deserve it because among other things,
the games you've just played with gun
control." And again, keep in mind that
although the gun control issue in
Virginia may not be the critical driving
force uh that will cause the voters to
shut down this mid decade redistricting
effort in favor of the Democrats, it
will certainly help at the margins. The
way I see it, it's kind of like the
straw that broke the camel's back. It
could be the issue that motivates red
state, red county, rural voters that
support the right to keep in the second
amendment to turn out to punish the
Democrats in a huge way. And again, if
the Democrats do not succeed with this
constitutional amendment that allows
them to redraw these lines that give
them four or five additional House seats
for the November midterm election,
there's a very good chance Donald Trump
will keep the House of Representatives.
It's going to be a close run thing. But
certainly shutting down this effort in
Virginia will be hugely favorable to the
Republican party. And that if you
support the Second Amendment is very
good because maybe the Republicans are
not perfect in guns. They're not perfect
on guns, but they're certainly orders of
magnitude better than the Democrats. And
look no further than the state of
Virginia, where as soon as the, you
know, the quote unquote moderate
Democrats get into power in Virginia,
they enact insane amounts of gun control
law because never forget that the
Democratic party, the progressive left,
the people that simply hate America and
hate Western civilization and hate
Judeo-Christianity and all these values
and everything that America stands for,
including our Constitution, including
our right to keep arms. Remember, all
those people will definitely vote for
massive amounts of gun control because
they have to take the guns away from
America to get America to become Europe
to be to turn America into the country
they want. They have to disarm us
because if you do disarm if you do not
disarm Americans, they're not going to
be able to achieve their vision of
utopia. And we understand why they want
to disarm us because they have big plans
for us and they don't want us to have
guns to make sure those big plans can
get carried through. Uh I'll let you
connect the dots with that statement.
Okay. So to close, bottom line is
there's a very important uh
redistricting election that is occurring
on April 21st in Virginia. If the
Republicans can prevent this
constitutional amendment from being
enacted, this will greatly benefit the
Republicans. And there appears to be
based on current trends among other
things a big backlash against the
Democrats in Virginia for some of the
game games they've been playing
including this massive push for these
non-gun control laws that are simply
over the top to say the least. So it
would serve the Democrats right if they
pay a heavy heavy price meaning they
lose the House of Representatives. They
don't lose it. They just don't capture
it in November of 2024 and they get
these silly gun control laws passed, but
they lose the House of Representatives
in the fall. And then in the court
system, the Supreme Court takes a few
cases to whack out and knock out these
ridiculous unconstitutional gun control
laws in Virginia. It would serve the
Democratic Party right in my view. But
again, the history of the future is yet
to be written. So, we will have to see.
But I do want to bring to your attention
the very positive trends about what's
going on in this attempt to capture four
to five Republican House seats for the
benefit of the Democrats in this midterm
election. And if we can shot that down,
that will be great for us. And it's very
interesting that there may be a backlash
against the Democrats because of their
push for gun control law uh brought
about in part by a Bangladeshborn
senator among others. And again, you
know how I feel about that and what I
think about that. None of this should be
happening. But again, uh I cannot
control anything beyond what I say on
this channel. Okay, with that said, make
sure you follow me over there on X4box
and Diner. Don't forget to subscribe
both the YouTube and the Rumble. And
I'll talk to all of you again real soon
here at the Forboxes D. Orders up. Table
2A.